we thought the war was over oh how wrong
we were
there's been another threat lurking in
the shadows in plain sight I'm talking
of course about cocoa melon nursery
rhymes I mean look at the subscriber
counts right now it's so close but guys
everyone is looking at the wrong channel
we were looking at the wrong channel his
family
so guys drumroll please
that's right guys it's called Coco melon
you guys probably never heard of it
before this channel has much less
subscribers than pewdiepie and t-series
true how do you think it will catch up
well wait till I show you the views and
subs this channel is getting every day
ok guys so look Jesus Christ as many
views every single day 69 million views
a day bruh that's the broad number and
it's a kid's channel you will not get
away with this actually that's pretty
epic
good job Coco melon good job if you
compare that to PewDiePie you'll see
getting a similar amount of subscribers
and views per day than t-series is
getting this past month the channel
increased its views by 20 percent
whereas t-series is only up by less than
1% if my math is correct then and 14
months of this channel will pass
PewDiePie and t-series so that wait how
many subscribers Coco melon now is that
83 million oh no they can't keep getting
away with it t-series piece we need to
join forces to defeat this evil they're
gonna take over both of us unless we
join forces I am joking of course but
still a my Indian nursery rhymes with a
bit sprinkle of PewDiePie will be
unstoppable what is it that Coco melon
does that makes them so goddamn popular
if you look at their channel it's pretty
incredible not gonna lie
their most popular videos almost ten of
them have over a billion a billion
how is that even possible let's check
out all the boxes that Coco melon hits
nightmare fuel check I can do that cyber
added something creepy a minute mark in
the corner for parents that don't can't
figure out how to read the bottom of the
corner let's put it a bigger on alright
gotcha sigh put it in the thumbnail
actually sigh put it in the corner right
now actually sigh inflate the numbers a
little bit oh yeah insight increase
saturation of this video oh yeah we're
already gaining subscribers and
as we speak I've been doing it wrong
I've been doing it wrong all this time
but what is coca melons videos what is
it that makes it to Park Valley I cannot
say that number without screaming Jesus
Christ dude
just in perspective how many people live
in the earth like nine billion do I got
that right
7.5 I'd even know and they managed to
get more views on 10 videos than the
population of the earth that's not bad
that's not bad a slight threat but they
have not won yet okay remember two
Orion's toy review I crushed him
everyone was like he's gonna take over
people I smashed him his channel not I
would never hit the child unless I have
to
of course I will hit a metaphysical
child cuckoo melon we need to get in the
boxing ring I challenge you Coco melon
Oh Flo gang too strong I'll fight me IRL
Coco melon I feel like I'm doing the
same thing here where I'm literally just
making really dumb an ironic jokes
against a company but we've already seen
how that went so I'm not going down that
road again
let's check out some Coco Maryland
classics this one is called I want to be
like mommy and immediately a pattern
that I've noticed on all Coco melon
videos is that they get a ton of
dislikes which is very confusing no
matter how many views on a video that is
always a ton of dislike what a baby is
clicking dislikes on these videos long
laugh this video this video sucks mom I
don't want to be like mommy at all just
like if they're getting this many
dislike what are they getting somebody
views video bad I just like it now how
does that happen
I'm so confused I don't understand but
we will once I'm done with you Coco
melon Coco melon shaking and crying
right now all right
I want to be my like mommy let's go what
did we go all right we need a cool intro
didn't we need a cool intro psych can
you do this
oh I needed a little mascot - I love
tiny tiny side next to me yeah
this video is falling heavily on site
during worship Jesus Christ at this
portion that makes no sense you give
birth to aliens god damn it this slaps
god damn it I was expecting really bad
and bener surrounds but this
[Music]
so what does the mommies do okay so like
where mom teach play but they're also
strong so they do hard stuff what do
they do hard stuff but difficult parts
[Music]
even though your face is insanely
disproportionate to your body hopefully
one day you'll grow into it I watch the
whole thing and I have no idea what
mommies does carwash song at least
animations aren't as atrocious as they
used to be I don't know if you guys
remember all the nightmare inducing fuel
that was going on for a couple years ago
[Music]
I can't think this is too good wait what
it's like a weird thing to teach kids
I've never wax a car and I'm 30 years
old wax the car guys let's get it maybe
that's what I've been doing wrong be
right back got a wax my car they also
have a dad song in here well I guess
mommies aren't that good after all I
told you
poor mommy she's crying no no no your
faces are all wrong no I never wanted
you
[Music]
Wow even mama Greece guess you don't
want to be like mommy huh sorry I want
this like this a couple more I need to
learn I need to learn we have the intro
we have all of it why aren't we gaining
subscribers side I feel like I'm
watching these and I know it I know it's
a kid's thing I know who but I'm still
waiting for the plot twists for
something horrific to happen it's like
what what am i doing right baby shark
you can't keep getting away with it
kokom Ellen exposed baby shark did it
did it unbelievable cannot believe it
literally cannot done believe it I'm 30
years old then I never wash my knees all
right I'll admit it I'm not afraid to
say it who washes their knees nothing
wrong with my knees by the way
Oh God legroom I mean look at the size
of my knees they don't need a scrubbing
curse you Coco melon maybe that's what
I've been doing wrong maybe I haven't
washed knees good enough our bare back
guys okay we're back wash my elbows did
they did they watch my elbows that did
it this one has two billion views I
can't believe it
this is the same song as earlier
it's just rehash content who would do
that I would never do that every video I
make completely original Wow it's the
same rhymes - look I can't believe this
unbelievable unforgettable expose
Coco melon expose yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes Coco melon floor can confirm
maybe cook a meal and not bed go Camilla
good cook a meal a flogging 20% muscle
increase you can see it I looked around
because I want to wrap my head around it
and they're not I know the answer and
the answer is just like kids I mean
parents just put the an iPad or
something in front of the kids don't put
on YouTube clearly that's the thing but
so many do they not have kids channels
for this
I'm so confused because an Instagram
they got no traction no traction on
Instagram at least I'm winning on
Instagram at least I have that
three little kittens
[Music]
legend what a legend good why is that
funny why did they cry if they found it
this doesn't even make sense
oh we need to keep the rhyme going they
found the mittens
they should be happy and also they're
not crying so many inconsistencies I
need to go wash my knees guys I don't
know about you I don't know why it just
feel dirty
kokom Ellen exposed but the real way to
the expose that someone everyone knows
this you look into their past
everyone has dirty secrets let's check
out kokum Ellen's oldest videos ok what
is this is in ok let's find something
that starts with N I can't think of
anything this is a newt what the hell
I'm 30 years old I don't know what a new
dish I wish it was comments I know you
did there remove it for kids stuff
Thank You kokum Ellen I'm sorry about
everything I said oh god the newt Jesus
you know I'm done no no no no the real
question is do they have baby shark oh
wow 1.2 billion T I need to make a baby
I need to just make a nursery song
[Music]
sorry gives me well that's a bit
redundant just end it then alright
all names aside I'm not trying to start
a whole thing against another company
cuz yeah okay but I did the math we have
about eight to ten months until Coco
melon takes over pudy pie channel at the
current growth rate subscribe subscribe
they're gaining hundred 200k what am I
getting what am I getting come on I
gotta be close at least nothing I get
nothing just one day million they may
have removed the subscriber marks but
you can still subscribe god damn me they
can't keep care to go away with it
subscribe to the channel unsubscribe
from Coco melon right now we're in the
endgame now voice I'm willing to take
help from anyone I can even Edgar my
tambourine may be dead but we will get
through this
thank you for watching this video it's
the end it's the end subscribe subscribe
hey hey dodo dodo dodo dodo dodo dodo
dodo hey bro-bro
[Music]
[Applause]